um so i'll quote from him just to help
us focus and
reflect in the face of many
petty forms of politics focused on
immediate interests
i would repeat that true statecraft is
manifest when
in difficult times we uphold high
principles
and think of the long-term common good
political powers do not find it easy to
assume this duty
in the work of nation-building much less
in forging a common project for the
human family
now and in the future thinking of those
who will come after us
does not serve electoral purposes yet it
is what authentic justice demands
as the bishops of portugal have taught
the earth is lent
to each generation to be handed on to
the generation that follows
so understanding all of our role
in handing on all of the fruits of our
neighbors to the
generation to follow let us ask almighty
god
to guide you all to give you wisdom
and to seek the truly common good
rather than only immediate interest
may he bless your work and bless all
those
who need help in our area at the time
and we ask almighty god to bless us all
now in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy spirit
amen
amen thank you father james that's much
appreciated i'm sure members to take
those words on board
thank you god bless you all
thank you
well tom i think you'll be started isn't
it slightly over
yes it has chair okay well uh welcome
fellow counselors and welcome to members
of the public as well on on youtube
uh to the full king of monday the 5th of
october
2020 we start first of all with
apologies although uh sandra do we not
do a roll call now or
we do do it roll call don't we yes
please chair so that i can ensure
everyone's here it's just it's not on
the agenda that's all
so we'll start with the roll call then
first
thank you chair councillor bowton yes
i'm here
councillor brenton present councillor
bright
yeah councillor brown president
councillor bushby roger councillor
christie
present hence the clark president
pence lacotte hankin present
councillor craigie yeah that's the dart
no yeah she sandra she is in the meeting
oh okay thank you tom
councillor gab here
councillor hackett present
chancellor haynes president
pencil harding yeah
hutchins yeah
inch president hencely james
yes he is with us as well sandra my
apologies present
thank you councillor jones
president councillor langford
president councillor laws present
councillor letter here
counselor lock present hansel mcgoff
present councillor mckenzie
present chancellor manley president
chancellor newton president
councillor pennington
president councillor rossi
yeah councillor watson
and councillor wiseman yeah
thank you chair oh thank you council
it's a full house
tomorrow reckoning anyhow so therefore
item number one then apologies for
absence is
irrelevant no chair sorry we do
we do have a couple of apologies oh
really oh
apologies from councillor heppo and
councillor ford
all right thank you very much good so
we've got
item two then cancel minutes i shall
read these through
page by page starting with page five
six seven
yes thank you chair um
yes the minutes matters are rising
councillor haines referred to a special
counsel meeting
first of all first of all it will be
good if the
minutes recorded at the special meeting
i wanted was on
the local plan and secondly
um this has gone on for months now i'm i
just
rather like some sort of response about
what
is going to happen yeah
certainly um yes having spoken to the
officers um
last week the um i'm going to call a
special meeting on
november the 16th because we have to
respond
to the government's planning um
proposals
which are quite significant and i think
that would roll up nicely
into that that meeting as well um
looking at the lga publication just
received today
the government's algorithm is proposing
that the southwest for example should
have a 39
increase in in new homes
so as i say i think i would fit in in
nicely into that meeting
thank you happy with that well it's just
that the consultation finishes on the
29th of october
so
but i think we've got a little bit of
wriggle room on that one
in order okay hope so chair thank you
so do i right so page seven then
eight nine
ten eleven uh councillor brenton i did
put my hand up for page seven
actually yeah you didn't see it oh
yes it's just below what councillor
haines raised actually the uh
where i referred to the government's
changes to the planning system
um the planning committee had a really
interesting presentation
from um our planning officers last
thursday
the ramifications of the government
white paper
are absolutely massive and
i i just want can i just check with any
of the officers present that we will
have that wriggle room as you refer to
it because the cut-off date is october
the 29th
and it is so important i know other
committees have had
a similar presentation from some of the
officers but i'm not sure every
councillor has had that
right shall i respond yeah please
uh check if you recall we we've we've
been talking about a couple of dates for
a couple of reasons for a special
council meeting the one we were
considering for responding to the the
planning reforms
white paper uh which would be
some time before the end of october so
either the 19th or
26th of october to deal with that
we were talking about a date in november
um for an item that's later on this
uh agenda which may be deferred but
we'll come to that item shortly
so we're planning to report to members
at a special full council meeting
our response for member input
before that uh deadline closes
thank you steve good i did um i actually
did scribble that in the corridor of my
minutes there and overlooked it well
done good
for that so uh councillor haines council
christie that should satisfy
that um that concern hopefully
all right thank you right so now where
was i was paige
12 i think 13 14
yes page page 14 sure
yeah um my written notice of
motion which was um passed by this
council about a report on affordable
housing camera
i have an assurance that this will i
assume that this
this will go to cnr for them to approve
whether to have a report or not
um but in which case it's going to take
quite a while but
it hasn't gone to cnr yet can i have an
assurance that it will be going soon
please
yes i'll ask councillor clark who's the
lead on housing is um
have you had some input into that
council clark
hello no no okay
shall i respond thank you again yeah
um so this this particular item is one
of the
big parts of our strategic plan which is
later on the agenda for this evening's
meeting
so that particular item would form part
of our action plan uh from the strategic
plan
and and into of course then a report
would be brought forward
but it's um not a simple or
small piece of work and not something
that officers within the authority
currently
have the skills to to do all of that
work so
it talks about setting up housing
companies building houses so it's not a
straightforward simple report to see now
it would be something that full council
would have to
consider because it has wider
ramifications than just
a simple single report thank you thank
you
so can we have an idea of how long it
will take for that report to be
done please um jeff i can i can respond
so as i said the strategic plan is on
the agenda for this evening
if that plan is adopted we'll start to
put together an action plan
so we'll need to look and look towards
members
to establish which items in the
strategic plan
you want to prioritize which ones you
want to do first second and so forth
because as you can see from the
strategic plan there's a lot of work
involved in delivering that so members
will have to determine the
priority of all those items right
okay did you all receive a copy of that
thing i sent out on the housing of the
working classes act
is that um anybody look at it at all or
yeah oh well never mind i'll pass on
15 16 17
18 19 20
21 22 23
24 25
26.
that's uh that concludes the minutes
with somebody i'm moving from the chair
somebody care
thank you yes so we'll take a vote on
that then sandra
thank you chair councillor bowton uh
for councillor brenton
bor councillor bright
or councillor brown for
councillor bushby
for cancer christy
or cancer clark or
penceler cottle hunkin or etzela craigie
or pencil dart
abstain
counselor gab for
pencil hair kit for
pencil haines or pencil harding
i'm stain councillor hawkins
or councillor hicks
or henson hudson or
james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford or
councillor laws or enslaver
or hansel and locke or
councillor mcgough for councillor
mckenzie
or penciller manly or
councillor newton or councillor
pennington
or councillor rossie
abstain councillor watson
oh and councillor wiseman
four right thank you very much for that
so now we come to item three which is
public contributions
uh we have some written ones and uh two
uh we'll start with uh actual speakers
so we'll start with uh councillor david
chalmers who's uh going to speak first
uh councillor chalmers are you there
yes i am um good evening council and
thank you very much for
for accommodating my request to speak
this evening
i'm speaking to you as mayor of northern
and was asked
at our full council meeting last week to
do so and it's in relation to the
torridge strategic plan
i won't um comment on on the particulars
of the plan because i'm sure that
uh there's the district councillors for
northern will
um will sort of make our representations
um fairly on those points
but um i just wanted to to right at the
very beginning
you refer to torrington holdsworthy and
biddeford
and we want to make sure that you know
northam
is by population the second largest
town in our district and also
with our tourist industry with our
beaches with our
festivals like recently the book
festival here in appledore we have a
major sort of um
tourist industry and contributed to the
local economy
and also we have the uh you know one of
the largest employers most significant
employers in in the area with the
shipyard about to open and i just want
to make sure that when you're looking at
areas i know they may be
listed because of being market towns but
the reality is is that northam is really
quite a significant player within turric
and we would like to
have that sort of recognized in the
strategic plan and be included
along the other areas if you're looking
at investing
and supporting and doing things for
business because
we require that as well and and that is
really
what i wanted to to my to make the point
tonight
thank you thank you very much councillor
uh i'm sure those ones should be taken
on board so the next speaker then is uh
mr lawrence
shelley see you there mr shelley
uh yes yes i am thank you thank you
if you'd like to proceed certainly yes
uh thank you very much chair and
counsellors for allowing me this time
slot
um the prime purpose of the planning
system is the achievement of sustainable
development
but i'm really profoundly concerned that
developments we have
coming up in northern and west ritter
provide no model of sustainability
not meeting the needs of residents or
future environmental challenges
and eight years ago as i'm sure you may
know the torrid housing needs
assessment registered 40 percent or more
in west ritter and northern
as over 60 compared with 30.1 percent
in the wider urban area the proportion
of older people will surely have
increased
since then yet the darden hill
development due in part i know to an
oversight
will feature not one bungalow for those
in this group
or with mobility problems young families
on the other hand
and the less well-off are also
disadvantaged
with the thirty percent expectation of
affordable housing routinely reduced
we have twenty one point two percent at
darden hill but as little as five
percent elsewhere
yet at yellen we have a developer
providing 34 percent
affordable housing and i do feel that 30
percent
ought to be the default with little
affordable housing
the younger generation will be obviously
forced to move away
and we know from this cpre report
that up to two-thirds of new builds may
be occupied by incomers
they may bring benefits of course but
surely this should not be at the expense
of our young talent
and enterprise so i would just point out
one clear need
for an up-to-date housing needs survey
please
to provide a strong evidence base for
addressing this situation
now the infrastructure contributed by
developers is a key sustainability
factor
time your provision is a requirement of
local plan policy st23
yet at dalton hill there's no certainty
as to when or even if the school will be
built
with local schools already full and key
highway improvements won't take place
until phase one is completed
other developments such as at land off
cornball road
will increase traffic flows and the
chances of accidents
to that already generated by deer park
development
and that brings me to the environmental
aspects
if and when the school is built pupils
and parents will be
car dependent with little or no safe
pedestrian access
particularly up stanhope and foskett
hills
residents of this and the cornbread road
development will be equally car
dependent
with little surety of appropriate
product transport and no shops within
reasonable walking distance
this cannot be compatible with the move
to a low-carbon economy
nor for there to be no solar panels on
this south-facing site at dalton hill
now these are only pointers i've picked
out to the lack of sustainability
other aspects may not figure in the list
of material considerations
such as the abiding appeal of a
viewpoint
from as far away as torrington you can
see the high point of daddon hill
backed by the happily interspersed run
of houses and bungalows along bayview
road
in various styles this will be replaced
by regimented rows of houses with roofs
identically aligned what a sad legacy
and what of their character rendered
elevations
with or without timber effect cladding
almost without relief
hardly a brick or stone in sight what
happened to diversity
to distinctive local character is there
any
i must say i find this lack of vision
and local connection
very dispiriting my final point is a
human one
i think counsellors need to be aware of
the cumulative impact
of decisions taken and of the
disconnection
people feel with the democratic process
residents tell me what is the point of
objecting no one listens anyway
and others directly impacted by this and
other developments
trucker developers having the upper hand
and of profit as king
one tells me they are totally despondent
of the outcome
and that the plan for the area in
general i don't know that i want to
continue living in this area
he said to me when local residents find
living here unsustainable
i do think we have to take notice can we
please put sustainability back
at the forefront of planning
considerations that would be my plea
thank you very much thank you mister
i'm sure members have taken your
comments on board and especially the
ones on the planning committee but they
too are very frustrated i know that
yeah so that so now we've got some uh
written
uh statements which uh steve harris is
going to read out now and these are
connected really with the notice of
motion from councillor
hankin thanks
yes thanks j the first one as you'll
note from the list there is has been
sent in
anonymously so if you're happy as well
to take an
anonymous statement uh well normally we
don't but in this case it's um
yeah i think it's permissible chair
councillor christie's raised his hand
yes councillor christie yes um i'm sorry
but i don't think we should take
anonymous statements because
um i argued for about four years that we
shouldn't take anonymous
letters on planning committee they used
to come in and they used to basically
slag off people and it really was wrong
and we stopped it on planning and i'm
afraid
if people want to express their opinions
they should put their name to it i'm
sorry but i don't agree with having
anonymous statements
well if i'm correct um council christie
i think this letter is is a personal one
in relation to health situation so i can
understand why some people would
not wish to have their personal medical
record
uh history rather put on on them in the
general public domain am i am i correct
uh steve
was that is that right um yes chase not
expressing um
opinions just telling a bit of a story
and a bit of a background to
the individual's uh situation and
experience
so it's not quite the same i totally
agree with what council christie said
about
anonymous um representations to the
council but this
this is slightly different as i said as
i think you'll find out when it's ready
chair councillor christine council
leather have raised their hands
uh councilman christie come back again
please yeah thank you for that
um that does put it into context and it
is slightly different i
i think i would agree with you but um in
the general run of things i i'm afraid i
i feel really quite uncomfortable with
anonymous
letters if it's not expressing your
opinion if it is just about the medical
facts then
yes i can accept that thank you right
thank you for that
uh it was counseling leather yes yeah
well
i was going to say i agree with
councillor christie we shouldn't be
making
anonymous representations of full
council
we'll do it whatever the reason we
should not be taking them
well i i think in this case i'm going to
allow it
so if you continue cancer sorry steve
hearst please
okay thanks chair uh so the first one
then um i wanted to share that sadly we
experienced a missed
miscarriage at 12 weeks in july this was
where i had no symptoms of miscarriage
and it wasn't until we went to our first
scan that devastatingly we were told
that our baby had no heartbeat i must
add
that we paid 90 pounds for a private
scan but had to travel to exeter for
this at 8 30
at night we did this so we could share
what we imagined
imagined to be the most amazing
experience together
as we were not allowed to go to our
first scan together which i feel is so
wrong
the whole experience was devastating and
i cannot imagine
how i would have coped going through
this alone at my nhs scan
i will do anything to help anyone else
not to have to go through this
on their own thank you
i think uh councillors i think you might
agree that
there's a good there was a good reason
why that should remain anonymous
thank you the next one is it yes chair
thanks it's uh from
briony mcdonald um and it reads i
understand i can email notes of support
to be ready at this meeting on the 5th
of october
i'm a third time expectant mother who
has to attend all scans and appointments
alone to date
i cannot fathom having had to do this as
a first-time mother
i am due in five weeks i now face the
prospect of further scans and consultant
discussions about this baby too due to
an issue
which has just been discovered while on
my own at a face-to-face midwife
appointment
i am terrified of the implications of
this not because of the issue
itself but because i'm having to face
this alone without my husband
the one person who knows me and who can
help me advocate reduce my
anxiety and keep me safe the worry is so
great that i find myself considering
tearing down the recommendations to
interventions because i would be alone
to have them
both prenatally and in labor this is the
danger women are in
there is plentiful research that having
a birth partner has become has better
outcomes for mother and baby
but the fear of being alone at these
crucial times is unnecessary
and at complete odds to the fact that i
go and sit on a bus with 40 people
but must endure past of childbirth and
pregnancy alone
third the third one from jody tutti
hello i am email emailing with regards
to the meeting of our partners being
allowed to be with women through all
stages of pregnancy and labor
this is our first baby and i've had to
do all the appointments alone
due to the rules this is a very very
scary time especially for a first-time
mum
i had no idea what to expect at each
appointment and also had no idea if a
heartbeat would be found at the first
scan
this is very this is a very worrying
time and to deal with it on your own
causes so much worry
and by not having your partner or friend
by your side to give you support
makes it even worse you miss seeing the
joy in your partner's face when you get
to see the baby for the first time on
the screen
luckily we had good news and all's okay
but there are many
women who have received devastating news
and they have had to deal with this
totally on their own
that can be so damaging for for a woman
when
for many having a baby it was all they
ever have to dream of
myself and many women who do their baby
soon are scared about their partner not
being allowed
with them at all stages of labour and
once baby has arrived
some women choose to have two birthing
partners as each one supports you in
different ways
knowing you have to pick one and not
knowing how long they will get
how long they will get to be with you is
adding even more stress and anxiety
to an already unknown scary situation
i feel it's also hard for partners to to
feel included
they also have questions they want to
ask and help
you take information as as it's all so
much to take
i feel so strong about partners being
allowed at all stages
it makes no sense at all to be allowed
to a restaurant with your partner and
friends
that all you have to do that you have to
do all the maternity things on your own
i really hope this gets changed it's
meant to be the happiest time of your
life and the most supported time
but it honestly doesn't doesn't look
like that at all
the next one chloe turner to whom this
may concern
in regards to the motion in question of
seeking to support expectant mothers
uh being held in the 5th of october i
have a few words of my account that i'd
like to put forward for the argument in
public contributions
at the end of may i was admitted for an
induction at
ndh where i spent 48 hours on the basic
ward
all without the support of my husband
and family i gave birth to my first son
by emergency c-section on june
1st was allowed two hours with my new
family
those moments were fleeting when i was
taken back up to the basic ward
with a baby baby whom i couldn't look
after because i could not move from the
pain of the operation
i spent three days alone in that ward
with only my screaming baby and the
rotating
midwives for company meanwhile my
devastated husband was
at home spending his precious paternity
leave crying and waiting for the phone
call that i could return home
i now suffer from extreme anxiety and
postnatal depression due to my
experience
and i feel it has affected how i have
bonded my first child
and that my husband will never get those
precious first moments back
if there is one thing i wish from this
statement is that nobody has to go
through what i went through
i hope there is a way my statements can
make a contribution
uh the next one from keely hewitt um
my local councillor cheryl cottlehunken
will be presenting a motion to the
councillors
i totally support this motion i would
like my voice to be heard
i am 35 weeks pregnant with my third
baby
13 years after my second the baby
is with a new partner and was not easy
to conceive and took time and help
this will be my partner's first and only
baby
he was not allowed to attend any of the
scans at the hospital
and sat waiting in the car for me to
return whilst i sat
there waiting to find out if everything
was okay i got to see our baby on screen
hear the heartbeat watch the little
movements
it's hard enough for expectant dads who
can feel left out
given that they do not experience the
same feelings movements that mothers do
as
a baby grows we ended up paying over a
hundred pounds for a private scan to
enable him to have the full experience
unfortunately it was amazing clinic an
hour
with an hour watching our baby and video
pics to take away with us
it was the first proper connection for
him as a dad
we are now having to discuss the
difficult situation around birth plans
i have gestational diabetes which means
there's a chance our baby will need to
be delivered early
possibly by c-section or by inducement
as the rules currently stand if i am to
be induced i will go to the hospital
alone
i will be on the wards alone the
treatment will begin
without me having my support with me and
most importantly
my partner is going to miss such a
significant part of our journey
you will not be allowed to attend the
hospital until i moved into the delivery
room
which will require me to be which will
require me to be over three centimeters
dilated
with this in mind i could if i react
slowly be left for hours
waiting to get to this stage or
alternatively as this has
has happened to a friend of mine react
quickly and by the time the hospital
contacted the partner and he arrived at
the hospital hospital
he very neatly missed the birth this is
unthinkable for me and unforgivable
the idea that my partner could miss a
single most amazing amazing event
and yet can walk into a pub in the event
of c-section i would need to remain in
hospital on award
my partner will not be allowed to visit
me there i will be alone with my baby in
the first
hours of our beautiful new life arriving
i cannot fault the staff at northam
district hospital who seem as upset by
these measures
as the rest of us but it seems
ridiculous that we
who are being so very careful due to my
condition and
in this predicament we are not going out
we wash all the food that comes into the
house we are not socializing
and yet if we wanted to we could we
could go into the into a pub for a meal
we could go on public transport or meet
with other households outside
the point is we are so careful to
protect ourselves
and the hospitals are so careful that
surely there can be no reason why
partners cannot attend
all scans appointments and be with us at
all stages of labour
scrubs and face masks can be worn
changes of shoes can be done
anti-back gel and washing hands this can
all be done
please please consider what strain has
been put on women
going through this process alone but
also unexpected dad's partners who are
isolated disconnected and distraught
have not been able to offer
their support many thanks keeley who is
the final one uh from holly sterman
dear sir madam i'm writing in support of
the proposal of lifting
reviewing the current restrictions that
apply to maternity services
at north devon district hospital i am
currently expecting my fifth baby and my
husband has only been able to attend my
20-week scan
other than this i have attended all
appointments and scans alone
i am under the care of a consultant due
to a health issue i may need to consider
the option of a planned cesarean section
this will be decided at my next scan and
appointment which under the current
restrictions i will be again
attending alone it would be greatly
reassuring to have my husband by my side
to help me make this decision
although this is our fifth child
together as we all know every pregnancy
and birth is different
and just as nerve-wracking yet special
every time the support a birth partner
provides is absolutely essential
and i feel helped has helped me cope
each time
i am dreading having to potentially go
into labor ward alone
and wait for my husband to be allowed to
join me at the last moment
the same applies to having to after
having had a baby
if i need to stay in which may well
happen
it is such a released relief to have a
loved one by your side
to help and i'm sure it raises eases
pressure on the already busy midwives
and other maternity staff
whilst i understand the difficulty of
trying to manage everyone's safety
during the current pandemic
and i do not doubt the level of care
maternity maternity staff are able to
provide i would be
so very grateful grateful if the
restrictions could be eased to allow one
partner to accompany expectant members
for appointments
and for their first and for their time
on labor and basketball
many thanks for taking the time to read
this of regards holly
st man thanks chair that's all
thank you very much steve well
councillors i think you'll
recognize this um very moving stories
there which will
obviously be debated when we come to the
uh cancer carl hopkins notice emotion
later on
so now we move now to uh declarations of
interest which is uh
item four well you know you need to
declare that at the appropriate time
uh agreements between part one and two
on item five there are no
part two items this evening six seniors
to consider
uh correspondence et cetera for by the
chair
as i alluded to earlier there i'm going
to call a special meeting
to deal with the uh
constitution on november
the 16th but more importantly there's a
deadline of october the 23rd
for members to put forward their views
and opinions so they can all be collated
so we have a sort of constructive debate
on the 16th i think uh this afternoon at
cnr it does highlight that
our constitution definitely not only
needs a good looking at but it uh
it needs some amendments that's for sure
and we're very grateful to councillor
mckenna
and mr clark well the council mckenna of
cornwall um
unitary authority and mr clark who's a
um lga uh person
for the input that they've had in the
meetings that we had before lockdown
but there's uh there's still work to be
done so that that
is something that will happen
so that as i say the constitution will
be looked at on that special meeting
uh now we go to questions
under rule a nine and there is one from
counts
uh councillor newton and i think you've
all seen that one and i think you've
seen a response
and i believe the supplementary was also
uh emailed in as well wasn't it
counselor newton would you like to
check on that
there hasn't been a supplementary
emailed as such
now oh hasn't it okay you've got a
supplementary opportunity
uh i have got a i have got to follow up
yes please sheriff i may
yes um can i can i just say that
um because a couple of people questioned
why
i was raising this this particular
question at a time when
some people would like to think that
this was gone and perhaps
buried i was concerned
that the costs involved
when we discussed it um was
all included in part two proceedings
and as a a need for
transparency especially for taxpayer
money
the the figures the accredit accredited
official figures
needed to be in the public domain uh and
at the moment they're not
they're all obscured by part two
dealings i think it's a shame
that either us as members or
indeed prompted by officers perhaps that
when something has been finalized and
inevitably
perhaps has to be dealt with in part two
because of
commercial sensitivities or whatever but
once that is passed
then perhaps we should be prompted to
actually release
detail or figures from part two coverage
because uh it's it
you cannot justify um uh
special protection for that information
and especially where we're dealing with
serious amounts of taxpayer money
um and you will
won't need reminding that this this um
especially when you
uh include the um
officer the priced officer time provided
to me by david earlier
uh including also the ali ovary overhead
rate
um that rises to just
over 1.3 million um and
before covid uh that accounted for
over 10 uh of our capital um
worth and of course we don't have any
unallocated reserves all our capital is
allocated so
your question is moving on
i could i i need to justify why we ask
the question
and it is important um because of course
the threshold for accountability of
taxpayer money is much higher than it is
for private business
mr chairman can i raise a point of order
please well
is it a point of order yes it is what
which one
the point of order being i don't have
the a9 question in front of me
i didn't even receive an email mr
chairman right public on live on youtube
what is the question please i don't have
it in front of me either
but the public don't have it i i don't
know because i would like to know what
the question was please
can i can i check can i read it yes
okay my question was to ask for a
breakdown of all costs born by torridge
district council
incurred as a result of the legal
dispute with kibbles
over the holsworthy agricultural center
the response to identify
any and all legal compensation
maintenance commission and court
directed
costs over the duration of the dispute
as well as an estimate of total officer
time
incurred um the answer
um just just hold on there counseling
just for one minute to check with the
solicitor that they're we're not
treading into dangerous water here
just hold on one second before you
respond carry on
um stacy uh councilman that that's fine
um
and just to confirm the um question was
sent to
all members on thursday and i i think
councillor cotta honkins just said she's
forwarded it to
councilman gough now so okay all right
okay as long as we're not treading into
part two stuff
okay carry on counselling um and the
response
uh we got um from officers
um and and thank you for the time uh
compensation settlement
was 525
448 pounds
uh kevin's costs were 434
608 um pounds
and torridge legal and professional
costs were 321
638 pounds making a total
of 1281
695 pounds um i've missed off the pence
excuse that
um there was then a summary of officer
time
which came to 419 hours
and it was broken down between uh the
different solicitors and
also severe paralegal um
so that was the the the question and
that was
the answer um i would ask now as a
result of this
and um and my aunt
my question would be um to to the leader
really
um and that is that
given the fact that this was a
significant
loss and drain on uh council
money um and it lasted and stretch i
know
over several administrations um
will there be any form of
follow-up or investigation to try to
learn
lessons from it so that we actually
avoid a repetition thank you
all right councillor james have you
would you like to respond or um
yeah uh well uh as
counselor newton said it goes back over
many years um
and several administrations i think we
have learned lessons because
our new chief exec is bringing in
much more of a accountable system when
we're dealing with stuff
in so much as that everything is
recorded and dealt with and
myself and the deputy dealt with
something the other day
where the deputy remarked to me that hoe
thorough
all the information was in front of us
so we have learned lessons
i can't assure cancer you and it won't
get it happen again because i can't
assure that
it would always be within my
jurisdiction to do so but i can assure
him that
i've learned some heavy lessons from
inheriting the kibble situation
um and i think we certainly not
certainly don't want to repeat it and i
will make sure that we don't
um and i'm quite happy to have a
discussion with counselor newton
on anything he thinks we could actually
do
to ensure um to safeguard that situation
so thank you thank you councillor james
that's fine
so under rule a9 there is uh there is no
debate or discussion about
these uh these issues so uh we'll move
on
chair councillor leather's raised his
hand is it a point of order
is it a point of order no chair okay
oh we move on point of order yes
um are we supposed to vote on the agenda
did we do that no
what agenda what are you talking about
the agenda for this meeting chair
sorry oh okay
i was looking at the minutes in the last
meeting i thought we'd voted
sorry uh we voted on
approving the the minutes of the last
meeting yes but that's all we vote on
my mistake
i think it means between part one and
two
well there is no part two there's
nothing to vote on
all right if there's no part two why
should we vote
okay so we moved to uh
item eight which was the constitution as
i've already explained
earlier uh that we have a special
meeting on this one because we need to
get this
as right as we possibly can is
councillor mckenna with us this evening
or
mr clark could you tell me tom yes
council mckenna is with us
all right good council mechanic i would
like to express my gratitude from the
council for all the work you've put in
and hopefully you'll be able to zoom in
from cornwall to join us on that meeting
if possible mr chairman i'd be delighted
to do so and i look forward to seeing
you all again
well i do i know you're missing out on
actually coming to devon but you know
you have to bear that um that privation
i can't but i can now catch up on
whether leeds united is signing anybody
this evening in the transfer deadline
though so
we're all good it's all good isn't it
yeah well done thank you so much
thank you meet you soon yeah cheers bye
yeah councillor peninson's raised his
hand is this a point of order
no i just wanted to thank councillor
mckenna and
for the work and it was a really good
leadership that they brought to the
meeting i was really impressed by it
and i would like to congratulate leeds
united beating manchester city last
saturday
all right all right all all right thank
you thank you
yes yes all right chair councillor
christie's raised his hand as well
okay there's a question can i just ask
you have you got any football results
for us have you
yeah the meeting is on uh the 16th of
november do we know is it a morning or
afternoon or evening meeting well it'll
be an evening one of full council
thank you okay chair sorry councillor
haims
and david hayes have raised their hands
sorry
sorry to go on about this i'm looking at
the minutes of agreement of agenda and
it was proposed and seconded and their
vote was taken so am i i'm being totally
stupid here am i
i i wouldn't dare comment
all i'm saying is i said to cancer
watson as there is no part
two on this agenda vote on part whether
we go into part two
all right yeah they said yeah i thought
i would say todd we're not in part two
but clearly
yeah never mind okay so uh we go then to
uh the strategic plan item
nine and i believe that um
either steve hurst is going to lead us
on this one
uh yes thanks jay i'm going to start and
then uh councilor james will follow
um so you've got the um strategic plan
in your papers
so just a quick uh recap of what's
happened so
back at the end of 2019 beginning of
2020
members started to develop the strategic
plan
for the for this term of office and had
input through a a number of workshops
we were ready for the draft plan to go
out to consultation back in march
but obviously the pandemic struck and
then we decided
it probably wasn't um timely to go out
to consultation at that point
so we decided we'd postpone it
since uh or during that time and
up until now we thought
in light of everything that happened it
would be good to have a quick
uh review and have a look at any impacts
and opportunities
which might have happened over the
course of the last six months which may
have either necessarily
necessitated or triggered a change to
summer or some slight modifications to
the plan
um so there are some very minor
modifications which members
approved at the last full council
meeting on the 12th of august
but it doesn't change the overall
direction
of the strategic plan so as i said
members approved that draft plan
at the last full council in august and
since then it's been
put out to consultation the consultation
run for a period of six weeks
up until the 23rd of september
and you'll see from your pack in
appendix one we had 19 responses
and obviously council of charm has
responded in public contributions today
so that makes 20
and it all received 72 comments
we've included all the comments received
in the papers so captured them and
sorted them into
the various themes of how the strategic
plan is structured
um if you've had a chance to look
through them quite a lot of them
request things of clarification asking
for some more
detail and there are some things some
slight misan understanding of some of
the services provided by torridge
at the moment the strategic plan is in a
high
level format and many of the comments
received
will likely be answered at the next
stage of development
which would be once your plan is adopted
uh we'd start to build up and construct
more detailed
action and service plans as i alluded to
earlier in responding to councillor
haims in terms of the
the housing strategy so that's the kind
of next phase
um so i guess what we're asking members
to consider
is to adopt the the strategic plan as it
is and set out
in your pack and with regards the
comments
uh officers will review each of the
comments received
and include that in a future report
alongside the action plan
indicating which ones are already
captured
and then highlighting to members which
ones
you may wish to consider either amending
some of the documentation
or further captured information so we
might wish to consider adding or mending
at future meeting when we present those
detailed plans
what that then enables us to do is make
a prompt start
obviously we've had the delay and i
think we all want to start to make some
progress on
what is already a delayed uh project so
we want to get those
amendments in at the later stage if
members are willing to do so
um i'll hand over to councillor james
the leader to make some
further comments councillor james would
you
thank you chair i made some bullet
points to try and keep
my brains square on this um
and basically i just do deal with it as
in the bullet points
most of it steve has covered uh i hope
you can all see the merits of approving
what we have
as all members together have developed
so far
i'm pleased that we've got so many
varied and constructive
comments back and i don't want to see
them lost
however i'm sure that you as much as me
i want to get on with progressing some
of these things
um which obviously has been difficult
because of the pandemic
but obviously there are things like
coaster home said like the hosing
and fairly relevant because at the
moment the government have just
announced
a whole load of money coming forward to
deal with hoes in particular
social hosing and so we need to have a
policy in place to see whether we can
actually
bid for some of that money or whether we
can make use of it with a
partner uh an rp a registered provider
um if we don't adopt what we have in our
plan no it will be 2021 before we get
started
and obviously that's two years down the
line
in terms of how long we've been a
council
you've had a chance to put forward all
your ideas and shape them
um so i'm just looking to get on with it
and what we we're proposing to do um
from tonight from td's point of view is
that if we adopt
the strategic plan in its present form
we would take all the comments forward
and i did
insist that all the comments are listed
so you can see them all
and make a a judgment on the different
decisions
and then we will work it through and
then we will bring
forward an amendment
to the strategic plan if we adopt it
tonight
that will show which ones fit into what
we do
what ones um would add to what we we
plan to do
and how we plan to implement it so on
that basis
i would just like to propose that we
adopt the street strategic plan
that's before you tonight with the
provoso that
we will look at um all the comments have
come forward
and the coasters will have an
opportunity to add on
in any additional comments and then we
will
move forward with it and come back to
you with a list of amendments
um at the next council meeting so on
that basis i recommend we adopt this
strategic plan
i hope somebody's
and i will second that and uh answer uh
councillor haynes yes
yes thank you chair um yes last last
night at um sorry i think it was like no
one
our full council meeting at northam
um we hadn't had a copy of the strategic
plan at the previous meeting
so we discussed it at um the meeting the
other night and there were a number of
comments on it will we i do i assume
that we will
maybe i have the chance as a rep as a
counsellor
for here for district councillor and
northern council of putting forward
those
points at the meeting that has been
referred to
and following councillor james has just
said
all the additions and amendments will
come forward at a
further meeting and they could be voted
on
right so nothing so nothing gets lost
through the mesh
of democracy okay yeah so it's thank you
chair so it's best if
northern town council sends those
comments to
to torridge to be included in the
meeting
yes thank you chairman yes
councillor locke has raised her hand
i was just going to second that but
you've gotten before me as long as
you've got the insurance
thank you i think that's that's very
important i think that the
the people who have done their best to
to comment on the strategic plan that
their views are expressed and
noted and acted on in fact
yes so uh we could go to the vote i
think
or did somebody else sorry did cancer
hitch did you want to speak
no no okay all right so i'll go to the
vote now
so those in favor please
um yeah
a recorded vote chair yes okay
thank you councillor bowton four
penciller brenton four pencil bright
four penciller brown four
councillor busby chancellor christie
harding or penciller hawkins
or chancellor hicks or
pencil hudson or penciller harley
or pencil hutchins or
hence the wrench for chancellor james
or ansler jones i look forward to the
detail but for
chancellor langford for
huntsville laws or cancer
mackenzie four penciller manly
or councillor newton
or councillor pennington or
chancellor rossi
or councillor watson oh
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much counselors
right we move on to item 10 winkley
neighborhood plan
which is uh been sent to you this really
is um
really uh something we uh it's a rubber
stamping exercise really it's this
weekly's plan
and um if you read on page 87 you can
see that the
uh the examiner's comments are very
praising of weekly's efforts in doing
the neighborhood plan
and uh we really are going to uh
just uh approve them is that correct
stevehurst
um
i'm sorry i think that's all you can do
uh because as you said it's
the weekly neighborhood plan and we
haven't got any
provision to change any of that okay so
we're going to uh
go to the vote on this one um
so we'll start it off if you like sandra
chair
okay you got councillor golf and
councillor christie raise their hands
okay all right councillor christie
christie thank you um can i just ask i
was
um at the planning meeting last week uh
when we discussed the government's new
consultation on the planning system
um i'm absolutely horrified to hit when
i ask the question do we need a new
local plan
in the light of these consultations and
i was told yes
now as i understand it neighborhood
plans have to comply with our local plan
is it all going to change now that we're
going to have to rewrite
our own local plan apparently by the end
of 2023
so does that affect these neighborhood
plans because
as i understand that they are written to
comply with our local plan
yeah respond
good evening everybody um i can
certainly respond on that matter
um we just don't know i think is the
answer to that
um
i think i think at the moment the
government's planning reforms are such
high level
that we don't have the detail in them to
really give a certain answer on that
certainly under the existing system we
need to have an up-to-date local plan in
place by the end of 2023
we have a plan that's up to date at the
moment it will last
up to date for a minimum period of five
years during that period we have to
review it and if it's considered that
it's still up to date
then we can continue and take it forward
um
certainly we will be looking at the
planning reforms in some detail
and we're looking at what we may need to
do in terms of taking a local plan
review forward
thank you thank you ian councillor
mcgoff
thank you mr chairman uh council gracie
raised a good question i want to ask ask
that myself but i will propose be
adopt or approve winkley's neighborhood
plan
thank you you've got a second room for
that audrey yeah sorry we've got council
laws council lock
council bush being councillor hodgson
has raised right okay
cancer laws do you want a second that
what councilman mcguff said so we've got
a secondary or not
um no i just feel is it for us to
approve
surely it's just for us to note their
plan
well should we ask the solicitor perhaps
i think that way if every if every local
plan has to be approved by
us what if we disapprove i mean yes
i'll take your point we'll ask sir stacy
is
is it for noting or just or voting
ian will come back if that's okay you
you challenging
thank you chair um there's certain
prescribed processes we have to go
through in terms of
neighbourhood planning it's the
responsibility of the
neighborhood qualifying body to prepare
the plan so in this case that's winkley
parish council
we then have statutory responsibilities
and duties that we have to take over
so the plan was submitted to us in
february of this year
we then had to put it out for
consultation in accordance with
regulations
we had to take it through an independent
examination
what's before you tonight is the
outcomes of that
independent examination and we as a
council have to make a judgment
whether or not we agree with the
recommendations of the examiner
the reasons for those recommendations
and whether
or not we as a council accept that and
therefore wish to take that plan
forward to referendum
so that's the next stage if there's a
clear clear result of that referendum
we would then have to take it forward
and adopt
or make as they call it in terms of
neighborhood planning the plan
so we've got a prescribed set of
processes at this point in time that we
have to go through
tonight is to take those decisions we
then have to formally publish a decision
statement which sets those out
and then we can start using that plan as
a material consideration
in planning decisions normally we would
have to hold the referendum within 56
days
due to covid we are able to we're not
able to hold that referendum
and we have to push it back till may
next year so
in the interim we are allowed to make
use of that should we take forward
all of those recommendations as a
package this evening
so basically we have to vote
indeed you have you have to make a vote
on whether or not you accept those
recommendations
from the examiner and the reasons yeah
it's not a noting it's for voting okay
indeed
i was also going to bring up the same
point as counselor
right okay government white paper yes
i know this is trouble it's uh there's
so much happening in planning especially
isn't it
so who's next um it's councillor bushby
elsa
[Laughter]
i can introduce myself chair uh my name
is ian roland and i'm a
senior planning policy officer here at
today council
thank you good okay so cancer
hudson was there i think that's correct
yeah thank you mr chairman
i regret that i was under the impression
that we were going to note
this report and due to sheer
volume of paperwork i haven't really
familiarized myself with this to be able
to
accept the recommendations
so therefore i will find that i will
have to abstain tonight
not that i'm not in favor of the
neighborhood plan
i'm but at the moment
i don't feel that i've had the
opportunity and it's neglectful of me
um but i will hold up my hand because i
was told that we had no
um i asked about this and i was told
that
we would be noting this report not
actually
uh approving it so um
i apologize for my abstention
that's quite right but as i understand
it you're still in a position to vote
for because although
uh we really don't have any
choice but to accept the the um the
examiner's
um conclusions because it is winkley's
plan
and um and we really are just doing
going through a legal process basically
as i understand it
however uh this is your decision at the
end of the day
counselor newton is next
chair if it would be helpful to two
members um
as the member for winkley ward
the the parish council winkley parish
council um
saw the inspectors have seen and
reviewed the inspectors report and at a
meeting that they had
a week ago uh they uh
expressed that they were content with
all of the comments of the inspector
on the plan that they're drafted if
that's a help to anybody thank you
yes thank you that's that's good that's
cleared that good who's next um
tom who's on the list here uh in romans
ian roland yes yeah chair i i was just
going to come back and just clarify that
we do have the responsibility to make
this decision this evening
it is a matter for this council although
it is the winxy neighborhood plan
the decision to progress with that plan
from a statutory perspective does sit
with us as a council
and we have to make the judgments that
are set at the bottom of
page 59 i think it is of your report
and they're the matters that we have to
consider now
your office advice is that the examiner
has considered all of those matters
and that subject to the modifications
that he proposes
that plan can be taken forward and is
appropriate
does meet the basic conditions and all
of the other legislative requirements
um and subject to two additional
amendments that are set out
in table two of appendix two and they
are they are minor points
of correction one is a point of
correction to do with
a change to the use classes order um
which came into force
subsequent to the examination and the
second one is a
minor error that was in the examiner's
report
so we do have to make those judgments
officers are satisfied that the plan
should proceed and go forward
the examiner was satisfied that the plan
should proceed and go forward subject to
those modifications
and as uh councillor newton mentioned on
the 17th
of of september the winky parish council
agreed
with the same thank you thank you for
that
so i don't see there's much need for
much more debate to be honest but
counselor bushby
you know i was just going to point out
that on the front page of the report it
says
an examination undertaken for torrance
district council
with the support of winky parish council
on the submission version of the plan
so it the examination was four
tolerances to council so
it's just the pecking order of local
government that's all it is it's not
really it it's
basically it's weekly parish council's
neighborhood plan and we really aren't
in a position to to stymie in any shape
or form because there is no
there is no reason for doing that so
there we go
uh councillor leather i think has got
listed as well
is he councillor leather did you thank
you chair
yeah i i believe it was proposed it
would accept these
um five recommendations i think somebody
proposed it and i'm second in it
well done because no it wasn't second
did you're quite right
but it is now thank you okay
so i'm going to go to the vote now
thank you chad sandra thank you thank
you
councillor bowton uh four councillor
brenton
four councillor bright four
councillor brown or hensler bushby
or councillor christie or
answer clark or penceler cottle hankin
for penciller craigie
or pencil of darts
four councillor dab
for cancer hackett
before canceler harding
or councillor hawkins
or councillor hicks or
pencil hudson we'll vote for
having heard the arguments for it
thank you councillor harley or
pencil hutchins or that's the wrench
or chancellor james or
ansel jones four
penciller langford four penciller laws
or chancellor leather or
counselor lock or pencil mcgough
four chancellor mackenzie
four penciller manly for
anselyn newton or chancellor pennington
or pence la rossi
or answer watson or
pencil wiseman or
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much councillors
so now we can move on to item 11
and i believe um who's which officer is
dealing with this one stephen
uh are they being taken together aren't
either coastal concordia as well or
yeah it'll be it'll be ian rollins again
for both volkswagen
did i just interrupt say that i should
be leaving the meeting now apologies
thank you very much for your
participation counselor thank you
so shall i start chair yes please
ian thank you thank you chair so this is
item 11. it's on page 105 to 148
of your reports and it's seeking the
adoption of the air quality
supplementary planning documents and for
its ability to be used as a material
consideration in determining relevant
planning applications
so the north american storage local plan
as you know was adopted back in november
2018 and to show its
effective implementation it's useful to
provide guidance on particular matters
around the plan it helps applicants
agents planning officers interested
parties
to make best use of it and it helps to
provide
clarity and consistency for all parties
and the way that we do that formally
through the planning system is through
the preparation and adoption of
supplementary planning documents or spds
it's important to note that we can't
create new policy nor amend existing
policy through supplementary planning
documents
all we can do is provide guidance on how
policy is applied
this is a joint supplementary planning
document with north devon council
and as it says in the title the spd is
about air quality
and matters around development and how
that impacts air quality
in particular it provides support for
the implementation of policy dm-02
in the local plan but also st03 on
adapting climb to climate change and
strengthening resilience
and also only for north devon in
relation to
bra which is to do with braunton that's
very specific to north devon
and it's because they have an air
quality management area designated for
braunton
and that's the only one in northern
devon so it's not relevant to to
ourselves
setting aside the aspects relevant to
north devon specifically
the spd provides guidance on how
proposals should respond to their
impacts or potential impacts on air
quality
through the lifetime of development be
that the operation
occupation or construction and or
demolition
in doing so it advises applicants
when a formal air quality impact
assessment may be required
and generally this is often about
traffic flows or proximity to traffic
or it may be around demolition waste and
dust
they're the principal elements that part
of the spd
considers it also provides guidance on
how development in the agricultural
sector
that might provide ammonia emissions
should be considered
and generally this is around the
provision of animal housing or
potentially slurry lagoons
they provide guidance on how we should
meet our obligations and statutory
duties to protect
designated sites species and habitats
and that includes our international
obligations
such as european designated sites and
that's that's slightly different to the
other element of it which is more
focused on on human health impacts
it also reflects on the adoption of the
national clean air strategy
which was brought forward by the
government and adopted
in 2019 in terms of the agricultural
element it recognizes the significant
adverse effect that ammonia can have
on specific habitats and it's part of a
wider government program
and commitments to address the impacts
of ammonia
in our area it tends to be about the
impact on triple sis and special areas
of conservation
officers from natural england recently
provided training to planning offices on
this
aspect of the spd and it described and
showed us the
effect of ammonia on habitats and
provided guidance on how it should be
assessed
and mitigated and the support that they
offer to us as a council on this matter
during the determination of planning
applications but also how they are
helping the farming sector
adapt to these new requirements
nationally
and on also the program of work that
they're doing more widely with the
farmers there
not just in and around planning they
also discussed
um their help and
advice they're happy to give to planning
agents because we
recognize that for some this will be a
new area and a new requirement on
planning applications
in reality the sbw the spd doesn't
introduce new requirements
but rather seeks to formalize guidance
about how these matters should be
considered
these are matters that many applicants
and agents will be familiar with already
particularly with larger scale
applications and they would need to be
addressed irrespective of whether the
spd is in place
what the sbd does is provides clarity
and consistency for parties
which hopefully is simpler quicker and
cheaper for everybody
we do recognize the potential burden
that the continuing transition to more
modern construction and process
requirements and associated mitigation
certainly on the agricultural
development sector
um can face and the impacts on our those
sectors of our community and our economy
but the spd isn't intended to be the
burden but simply to provide the
guidance
around for applicants on these matters
the spd has been subject to consultation
back at the end of last year
and there were 57 representations 29 in
support
two support subjects or amendments 13
objections
further 10 comments that were general
and three that were unrelated to the spd
the sbd was subject to a range of
amendments to reflect those
and in particular the addition of the
consideration of the ammonia
a technical matter on the air quality
impact assessments and references to
revised national policy including the
air strategy clean air strategy were put
in
copies of the representations and their
considerations are provided
appendix one to this report following
that consultation members of local plan
working group
were given the opportunity to comment on
the revised draft with an associated
report
earlier in the uh that was around march
this year
at the commencement of lockdown they
were intended to be able to review that
at a meeting
of that working group however that did
not happen and take place because of of
the
coveted pandemic we received no
responses from the local
working local plan working group members
in relation to the report
a copy of the proposed draft sbd to be
adopted is provided at appendix 2
to the report it was adopted earlier in
the year
by north devon council that was because
of a pressure
and a requirement to get the guidance in
place in relation to the air quality
management area for braunton
and a pressing need to get that done it
was subject to an amendment at strategy
and resources committee at north devon
today which clarified an element that we
noted as a
needed correction as i say it was
intended to be brought forward before
the council earlier in this year but
deferred due to cronus
virus and the pandemic we'd like to
direct you to the recommendations and
report on page 109 of your agenda
and uh ask you to give them due
consideration
thank you chair thank you ian thank you
very much for that i've got
uh councillor leather i think first is
that right tom
yeah that's correct yeah thank you guess
the leather
thank you i'd like to move the
recommendation on page 109 that we adopt
the air quality
air quality supplementary planning
document thank you i'll second that all
right next person then is uh cancer
pennington
uh thank you chair uh page 142 7.3
um in north devon torres levels of
ammonia
rates of nitrogen deposition um can you
uh give a uh a note to that to where you
found that information and made that
assertion i see
prior to that you've gone through the
clean air strategy it would just help
explain to people in the agricultural
sector what you're basing that comment
on
it doesn't appear to be noted and i'll
be grateful if you could put the note
where that assertion is please
can i just take the page number again
please just page 142
and the 7.3 it says in north avenue
targets the levels of ammonia and rate
of nitrogen deposition
are above those considered to cause
muscle species habitat on such sites as
bronton burrows and the cone grasslands
um and there's no note to say where that
assertion has come from
when explaining to particularly the
agricultural sector where they've had
some difficulty with
trying to to modernize agriculture
where you're basing um your strategies
on
um if you can explain to people what the
research behind it is
i think it makes it easier for people to
understand where you're coming from
yeah all right so
so i i believe that the information in
there became came directly from natural
england
certainly it correlates with information
that we were presented with
at officer training by natural england
in their in their presentation slides
just there last week in fact and the
the gentleman from whose air quality
lead for devon cornwall
was able to pop up a slide and i can
certainly circulate that to members if
they're interested
which showed that certainly we have a
prevalence of ammonia
as an issue around here as as you may
well expect
where we have a high prevalence of
agricultural practice
so certainly that's that's where that
comes from okay
thank you for that in governor james
okay
right thank you chad i'm nervous about
this i've spoke to ian
i feel the agricultural one was slipped
in a little bit
we spent a lot of time on um not
discussing the air quality because it
was basically around
borneon and this has been sucked in a
little bit
um and i do worry it's the thinner edge
of the wedge um agriculture is so
important to the area
it won't affect me because i've gone
organic with the few cattle i've got
and we've turned some of the farm over
to a nature reserve
so it won't affect me i did see on
television the other day
that allah which is the con co-op that i
used to belong to
they're doing experiments in catching
methane and
ammonia and i was supposed to this
afternoon but i was on another call
um i'm a part of an exeter university
group
looking at this sort of stuff and
unfortunately i couldn't do two means at
the same time you try but it's not that
easy um so i dealt with the one i did i
spoke to
exeter this afternoon and they're going
to send me the stuff
so i am nervous about it ian um
you know aquaculture is so important to
this area
i'm not in favor of large farms and
massive slurry pits and
um i'm almost but not quite on a
nzl area which is which restricts the
amount
amount of ammonia fertilizer that's used
but as i said i haven't used fertilizer
on the farm nearly three years now
but i still am very nervous that
we are bringing stuff in that i don't
think we discuss properly
as a member of the working group um and
there is information in there
his counselor penitent says is where did
it come from
so um i'm quite happy to support it but
i would like that noted right
thank you for that councillor pushpin's
next on the list
thank you chair um well i think the uh
the point that was raised was 7.3 on
page
142 um i think completely undermines the
credibility of this document in my eyes
because
i wouldn't believe one thing that
natural england say
they've been proven to be you know
virtually a bunch of liars in my my
opinion
um whenever i i've had meetings with
them
um so you know i i cannot support any
document
that has references to natural england
as being a main participant
in producing this document all right
your vote so the next one is council
jones
thank you chair after what council james
just said i'm not sure whether i need to
but i will declare an interest being
that my family are farmers
right thank you so
councillor haines is next
thank you um yeah i do take council
james's point
um about his concerns but
i congratulate him on going organic but
the fact remains that
we have in this area um certain farms
that have massive
amounts of cattle with huge slurry tanks
and there's nothing to say
i mean it looks like this is a
development which is going to
go on in terms of agriculture and
it's not just natural england that has
said something about
have put in the thing about ammonia it's
as i understand it there is pending
government legislation
um to deal with the ammonia um
pollution and it doesn't just affect
habitats it affects people as well
in their respiratory systems as i
understand it so i think it's very
important to cover this in
the document uh before i call you back
in
in i'm going to get councillor newton
and cancer coddle honking first okay
so councillor newton yeah thank you
i was just going to reinforce that that
simple little paragraph
of 7.2 actually has
potentially huge implications
and is far more important
than it appears just sat there and for
the agricultural
uh community that can have enormous con
considerations i'm not saying we
shouldn't be going there but i'm not
quite sure that a back door entry like
this
is the way to tackle a major policy
of how we farm and et cetera in the
future
because that's a little bit what this is
actually it's slipping something in
um trying to constrain people
um almost via
an indirect method so i'm i'm not i'm
not
uh happy with that personally thank you
thank you cancer coddle honking um we're
only a small family farm but i better
declare an interest as well
okay thank you for that so uh ian i was
going to call you back in again
yeah yeah thank you chair um i i think
i'll come back in terms of the
the matter about natural england um
certainly they're they're a statutory
body they're the expert body that we
have to go to
um and we seek advice from clearly
we we we have to to understand their
viewpoints
and um as as one of the members said we
are moving to having legally
binding international targets on ammonia
this isn't intended to
be a break on agricultural development
it's not meant to prevent agricultural
development
it's about making sure that we're
getting the appropriate information
before us in terms of planning
applications it's requiring
applicants to prepare what's called a
scale assessment
which looks at the levels of ammonia
that will be discharged from the
development
and if it's over a particular level then
it's about providing mitigation
and some of that may be very simple it
may be about putting a
tree barrier in place it may be about
putting a cover onto slurry bits
it may be about different types of
mechanical flooring for
for um cattle sheds etc
so it's not meant to be a barrier to
developments
it's certainly the way that the
government is moving as you see
in that section in in the report or in
the spd
so that's that's our responsibility and
it's about our responsibility to these
european
protected sites this special areas of
conservation and about protecting those
triple sis
and our obligations under existing
legislation to
to affect those so it's not meant as i
said it's not meant to be a barrier
it's only meant to be the guidance it's
not inventing policy
the policies are already already there
in our local plan
it's about making sure that we're trying
to support that sector in this
transition
and that we've got that guidance in
place to assist with that chair
okay thank you i'm going to go
councillor harding and then i'm going to
do the vote then
so kenneth i do need i do need to speak
on something sir
yeah well right well after councillor
harding
i'd just like to declare and interest my
son and my brother as farmers so uh all
right
that's good enough cancer push me and
then i'm going to go to the vote
thank you chair um i would just like to
point out you know as
um as torridge councillors torridge
owns 640 acres of a triple si in
northern um
which is basically under the under the
management of
natural england now later on in the
agenda there's
there's there's an agenda item which
refers to
golden boroughs and see defenses etc
and the biggest obstacle to doing
anything on
northern boroughs in terms of cultural
defenses has always been
natural england they are the ultimate
authority
and they have the right of veto on
virtually everything we want to do there
i don't want to do anything to
strengthen
this this is an air quality uh policy
this is actually
cancer pension but i'm going to indulge
you to
come in hard to get on and i don't
understand
i'm sorry i did i don't know it got
crosstalk
sorry about that cancer hicks uh
thank you uh as a member of the
torridge north devon local planning
committee
this document came to us and it was
critical
for braun anything to do with torridge
was almost irrelevant i i do agree with
councillor james
here more significantly i note that
for some months now our planning
officers
have been demanding certain documents in
accordance with this
document even though it had not been
adopted by torridge
and when people queried what it was
about
nobody knew when it ended up they had to
have discussions with natural england to
find out what it was about
what they were demanding because people
were applying for slurry stores in
heartland and having to produce
documents because of ssis
at thornlead moore
it's not well thought out it's natural
england running wild
i'm not happy with it and i can't vote
for it
right thank you cancer hicks the
students have popped up a few other
other people now for some reason
councillor brown for example
did you want to speak no chair i didn't
have my honda
yeah councillor haines and ian rowland
wants to come back
right okay then then we must go to the
vote then
thank you chair just just having a quick
look on the web here about the effect of
ammonia
um one site plays a major role in
creating particulate matter
one of the biggest threats to people's
health from air pollution including
emissions from farms
um that goes on and on on this website i
mean there
are clear has hazards to human health
and not just to biodiversity thank you
thank you for that right in i'll let you
uh
have the last word okay thank you chair
um certainly we're not trying to bring
this in by the back door and it's um not
not the work of natural england alone
um we did take it to local plant working
group
and and we have given it due regard in
terms of of the opportunity for comment
there i believe
um what i will say is that it certainly
hasn't been used by our planning
officers
in terms of decision making up to now
that's not a not something they were
able to do and in fact
they won't have had many of them won't
have had sight of that
so natural england may be requiring
scale assessments
in line with what the guidance is going
to be requesting
but that's coming down at the national
level from the clean air strategy
and from the implementation of of
natural england's
guidance and advice and requirements
this this looks to be getting in place
and and putting in place guidance to
support that clean air strategy
and the national direction of travel so
certainly i think
with or without this we'll still be
needing those assessments that council
hicks
uh alert to thank you chair okay thank
you for that
so the recommendation is on page 109
and it says adopt the air quality
supplementary planning document
s pd as set out in appendix 2 as a
supplementary planning document
and to be treated as a material
consideration in the determination of
relevant planning applications so
sandra will go to the vote now it's been
proposed and seconded
thank you chair councillor bowton i'm
staying
councillor brenton or
councillor bright or
councillor brown borah councillor bushby
very much against councillor christie
oh councillor clark
or councillor cotton hanken
abstain chancellor craigie
or cancer dot
counsellor gab abstain
counselor hackett four but with
reservations
councillor haims or
councillor harding abstain
cancer hawkins or
councillor hicks against
can't
four councillor james
said four but i'm going abstain
so you're abstaining sorry yes i'm
abstaining i said earlier
that i was i would um not oppose it but
the more i've heard the more concerned
i've become
thank you cancer james councillor jones
i'll have to abstain counsellor langford
for pencil and laws
laws against
cancer leather or
pencil lock
oh she's she's left the meeting sorry
councilman mcgrath strongly against
council mackenzie
against councillor manly
abstain councillor newton
against cancer pennington
against and declaring a personal
interest because i farm
uh councillor rossi against
councillor watson oh and councillor
wiseman
against okay two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen one two three one six seven
eight
nine one two three four five six seven
eight nine
ten eleven sure the vote for that is 13
4 9 against
and 11 abstentions
right so it was carried
thank you cancer so we now will go on to
item 12 coastal
concordat which is sort of in again
it is thank you it is chad i will try
and make it as brief as i can
um but i do wish to explain it to you um
so the recommendation is to adopt the
coastal concordat
uh development associated activity in
and around the coast
can often require various types of
consent uh often from different bodies
it could be this us as a planning local
planning authority
it could be the marine management
organization it could be
an environment agency or the bodies
the coast of concord is a national
initiative with the intention of
delivering better coordination between
the consenting regimes
in doing so is intended to provide a
better experience
for customers for regulators and for
other interested parties
it's currently a voluntary initiative
but is being promoted by defra
and the government more widely who are
keen to see consenting authorities
become signatories
the 25-year environment plan that was
adopted i think it was last year
includes a commitment for all local
authorities with coastal interests
to become a signatory by 2021.
currently it's a non-binding agreement
so we
would not be committed to retaining it
the concordat is relevant for consenting
of coastal development
where more than one body has a
regulatory function
the simple purpose is to better
coordinate the involvement of those
bodies
for the benefit of all but particularly
for the customer
it's based on five high level principles
a first point of contact
and if we were the first point of
contact it's simply about sign posting
to those other organizations
and those are the contacts where they
may need to be getting other consents
it's about appointing a lead authority
to coordinate
now that may be ourselves as a local
planning authority or maybe one of the
other
regulatory authorities and generally
it'll be the one who's got the
the the most significant impact on on
their consenting regime that would take
that
role it's about dispensing or deferring
responsibilities if possible to make it
simpler and faster and more effective as
a regime
it's about agreeing requirements early
ideally at the pre-app stage
so there's not expense and time wasted
later on
it's about providing a coordinated
service so it's about the appropriate
people
who are dealing with different
applications simply talking to each
other
and making sure that they're asking for
the information at the same time
and for compatible information so people
don't waste time and money
they're seen as simple actions but with
multiple potential benefits
to us as a regulator and to applicants
reducing duplication for people simple
signposting
when it can be quite a challenging thing
to be getting to grips with
about streamlining processes about
transparency and consistency
and efficiency savings for all parties
and it's about meeting
the emerging responsibilities under the
25-year environment plan
so it relates to intertidal development
so that's
between high water and low water for
torridge this is along our coastline
but also inland up to our mean high
water mark so that'd be near where
gifford
and there are some exceptions around
things like national
nationally important strategic projects
so
we don't see many of those down here
for the council as a regulatory body the
main aim would be about
being invite an advisory role and
coordinating with other public bodies
in reality we tend to try and do this
now
and so it's about just formalizing that
so it's about signposting two of the
bodies as a first contact
highlighting that they may need consent
licenses permission
approval from other other parties and
the other bodies should equally
reciprocate
to ourselves it increases efficiencies
for all parties
it means that we're less likely to be
missed out or
for applicants to miss out on a on a
license that they may require
which may delay development
responsibility remains with the
applicant and this is important
at all times to gain those consents so
we're not liable
in terms of any of those aspects and the
second element is to designate
a lead authority so it's about
coordinating and seeing who
is best placed to take the lead on any
particular projects or developments
and again that's about the purpose of
improving efficiency and removing
duplication
but importantly again it doesn't
delegate any decision making authority
to any other body that remains with us
simply about coordinating those
requirements evidence timings etc
from our perspective it should provide
efficiency savings for all of those
involved in coastal development
including the council so our development
management services
the coastal column court app will
directly apply to the council in its
role as a regulator
and that's principally in terms of
planning and its development management
function
however it will also potentially have a
positive impact for us as a customer
of these services for example our
property services team
when we seek to carry out development
projects in and around the coastal
locations ourselves
or in terms of works that are required
in terms of our role as a coastal
authority clearly it could also benefit
businesses and residents making it more
straightforward cost effective and
easier to deliver development
be that for the coastal defenses or
other forms of development in this area
it won't however water down the
protections that are there
plymouth council from the city council
cornwall council
and dorset are all signatories already
and north devon council has agreed
earlier in this year that they will
become a signatory to it
signing up is as simple as a letter from
the appropriate officer being sent
to defra planning officers benefited
from some presentations from the marine
management organization
at the end of last year and some simple
guidance has been prepared to support
the introduction of this
i will draw your attention to the two
recommendations on page 153 of your
report
and i'll pass back to you chair thank
you very much ian
yeah so it's been been endorsed by a
lead member
councillor watson and also by councillor
james so
i'll presume these two councillors would
propose a second did is that right
councillor
james or councillor watson
i have had a discussion with you sorry
cancer james yeah sorry i've had a
discussion with ian
the only thing that worries me is if
something falls between the groups
because each one is responsible for
informing the others
if something goes wrong we have a
situation where they will all say
well we told you or whatever so i'd just
like
to convey to you that i think that
we need something to ensure that
everybody does sign up to it
and there's some way of accountability
um
so that when something goes wrong they
they don't say well we signed up to it
and we did tell so and so but um you
know
i think i'm just a little bit nervous
about the accountability of it
in principle it's a it's a marvelous
idea that everybody
works together um and it should help us
on the coastal stuff but i'm still i
will propose it
but i still am nervous about
accountability
thank you you proposed it we've got a
seconder i'll technical
thank you councillor watson so we got
councillor bushby
thank you chair well once again
this is this is another attempt i'm
convinced uh by natural england and
environment agency
again coming in through the side door to
flex their muscles
and you know influence on areas that
they've probably been a bit weak on in
the past
doing it um you know as a stand-alone uh
authority
signing up to this you know just gives
them more credibility i'm afraid
i cannot support it right thank you uh
next one is uh is councillor watson did
you speak
no no all right okay council hicks
for you on the list well
cheers ian roland would like to come in
oh sorry
we'll come back in right yeah i was i
was just going to come back on
councillor james's uh point uh
in the international accountability i i
just wanted to reassure him
that we we take that and we know that
i think if anything this process should
increase accountability
it should increase transparency and
increase that that
flow of information between between the
different regulatory bodies
i mean in terms of counselor bushby um i
i certainly know your concerns
um but i think if it can reassure you
it's about
we would retain all of our independence
in terms of our decision making
none of that passes between the bodies
it is about the flow of information
and the coordination of information
rather than the coordination of the
decisions that each party needs to make
that would remain independent for for
each of those bodies
it is simply about making it easier and
quicker and simpler
for for all parties involved thank you
tom is there any anybody else lined up
because i don't know nobody else chair
all right i've got to go to the vote now
so the recommendation is on
page one five three
so sandra if you ready okay
thank you chair councillor bowton uh
four councillor brenton four
penciller bright or chancellor brown
or pencil bushby against
councillor christie oh
cancer clark or that's
total hanken for chancellor craigie
or penciller dart
for councillor gab
four councillor hackett
four penciller haims or
pencil harding
against pencil hawkins
or councillor hicks
against cancer hudson
paul councillor harley
or chancellor hutchins for
councillor inch for
councillor james paul
councillor jones abstain
langford for
councillor laws or
councillor leather or
councillor mcgoff
against counselor mackenzie
four councillor manly
or henson newton or
cancer pennington
councillor rossi abstain
pencil watson or councillor wiseman
four one two three four
yeah that's 26 for five against and
two abstentions thank you sandra that's
carried yeah i'm sorry
i regret i have to leave the meeting now
thank you very much
uh thank you very much council aims for
your participation this evening thank
you
thank you so item 13 petitions
we don't have any petitions so we go to
14
which is notice emotions and a
is from uh councillor mcgough
and i have to say if if this is approved
by council
it would go to the property and major
projects group
for a report so councilman golf would
you like to leave it we i mean obviously
we've read your notice motion but uh
let me try to add to that uh thank you
mr chairman
um obviously just trying to gauge these
support from the members
i i do feel it's very important for
victoria park and torres in general
to good housekeeping generally to be
honest um
and it will be a cost saving to the
council as you can see
in the motion there's written there i
have submitted this here before
and i do like to follow things up and i
i believe it needs to be followed up
and what what committee mr germans you
said it's going to go to please uh
a property and major projects group
it'll go to first of all for uh
for um uh costings and assessment
okay what then to see an arm mr chairman
well
they would make a recommendation yeah
okay okay
very important for the area so yeah
thank you i would um
i would uh happily second the the notice
of motion
i have to say i've uh i do regularly see
in the summer of people from all over
north devon i've known because i've
lived here all my life
who come over specifically to go to
victoria park where the
the paddle pool which um as you as you
rightly point out and you notice motion
the only one in the area
may i
i believe you're wrong chair i believe
there are two outside pools in torridge
we have a rock pool at westwood ho now i
fully appreciate that
um the proposal of this motion council
mcgoff
is not overly familiar with um that fact
at westwood it's not in his ward but
um we do have that second pool and
during my time as lead member for
internal resources
i believe we had issues with glass going
in that pool
so both pools have this issue
in common so um maybe
cancers would like to bear this in mind
when they make the vote
i'm sure councillor laws would um
would probably raise that point because
i know full well that
he's aware of the rock pool there and
i've just stepped in first
thank mr chairman thank you i i would
say
uh councillor hackett that actually
there is absolutely no comparison
between the two pools
no rockville is they could cost a
substantial amount of money to drain and
get the glass out
and it's just the point of fact there
are two pools there it's not the only
one
as westwood hoe residents would jump up
and down about
thank you chair okay can i
come back please yeah yeah lovely
to catch happen obviously the tide ebbs
and flows twice daily so twice daily
that pool gets cleaned out
and it's worlds apart from what they're
actually there
the type the pool self cleans itself i'm
not saying about the glasses things like
that but the tide comes in ty goes out
we don't get that victoria park
thankfully
all right okay we'll um uh
who's the next one tom on the list
councillor jones chair
jones right okay councillor jones well i
actually just wanted to
second councilman goffs just thank him
for bringing it forward once again
right thank you okay uh next one tom
councillor chris teacher christy
i'm afraid i too was gonna second it but
uh you're going fast uh jim
um i would just say that uh the pools
have nothing
in common between one at westwood one of
victoria park
um the pool will actually beget it was
built by the uh bit of a borough council
as a
a yachting pool um it's never been used
for that
uh generations of children uh in
torridge have come
to that pool and i think this is a
brilliant idea because you do get the
occasional
idiots who do throw glass in and it it's
it you have to drain the whole pool of
sun so i think this is a great idea and
i will vote for it
right okay uh tom anybody else yeah
councillor bush being councillor law's
chair
right okay councillor bushby point point
of order
chairman yes i don't think we
we don't we're not supposed to debate
motions are we now no we're what we're
trying to do is to
see whether this goes forward to uh
shouldn't we just vote should we just go
to the vote mr chairman
i would i would uh totally endorse what
you're saying really but uh we
because there was some misinformation
going on here i think we needed to
clarify that but um you're quite right
we should go to the vote on it
to go off to either you agree with it or
you don't go to property and manage
major projects group so we will do that
thank you councillor inch
um sandra will go to the vote
thank you chair councillor bowton
uh four councillor brenton
paul councillor bright
four councillor brown four
hence
four pencil a dart
four answer a gap four
cancel a hacket four chancellor haims
sorry he's left councillor hiding
for councillor hawkins
or councillor hicks
or pencil hudson oh
chancellor harley or penciller hutchins
or councillor inch for
councillor james or cancer jones
or penciller langford
four councillor laws four
antenna leather or councillor mcgoff
four councillor mackenzie
newton four chancellor pennington
councillor rossie four chancellor watson
or councillor wiseman or
that's unanimous chad thank you very
much
thank you oh counselor mcgovern my good
luck with this one you never know
so here we go we're going to uh be
written chair counselor wiseman's got
his hand raised sorry
cancer wiseman only by accident
you don't have to raise your hand when
you're at home cancer-wise when you just
go you know
nobody's watching okay so b then notice
a motion from councillor mackenzie
um this would uh require if approved go
of a full report back to
to full council actually because it's
quite comprehensive
uh notice emotion as you can all see so
uh i don't think we'll be um
having much debate on this in this at
this stage but councilor mackenzie have
to make your case for it
and we'll need a secondary if that's
approved okay
okay well after discussions with the
lead member for resources which includes
coastal defenses
um i'd like to withdraw my notice of
motion at the moment because
there is this is already under um
investigation
by um a body um
and uh i think that they are
progressing with this matter at the
moment but um
if i don't believe that sufficient
uh progress is made in a timely enough
manner
then i will you know re-introduce this
notes of motion at a later date
but at the moment i would like to
withdraw it right okay
we have to take a vote on that as to
whether you can redraw it or not
um i think um stacy will confirm that as
an under our present constitution
you just it isn't quite as simple as
just saying i'm going to withdraw it you
have we have to vote
to withdraw it is that correct
chair um it hasn't been voted on it
hasn't been proposed and seconded
so and there's been no debate so um
council mackenzie can just simply
withdraw
the motion okay all right so it hasn't
been as long as it hasn't been proposed
a second is that what you're saying
right okay right so okay that will pass
in on to
c then which is notice emotion from
counselors jones and hutchings
i have to say that if i was a thin skin
sensitive individual i would take
umbrage at this particular notice of
motion
in safaris i don't like people to assume
where
what charitable or what other uh
organizations are cared to support or
indeed any other council for that matter
okay but you uh
i think it's also been superseded am i
correct councillor james over the
business of cnr this afternoon to
vis-a-vis um
the uh council of grants fund
councillor james well the emotion hasn't
um having accepted the situation with
um what we've proposed now for the car
parking
there should be sufficient funds now to
reinstate the
36 000 that was allegedly
taken away um and therefore the grant
system is now
restored um so that's why
um the other issue is is whether
the council or the full co whether
the meetings that were missed because
the covert whether the chairs actually
made no contribution to the council and
the fact that we have now had
far more and we've already tonight
proposed two more extraordinary meetings
we've now almost doubled the number of
meetings that we missed
um and that is point of order
right sorry who was that councillor
jones chair
yes councillor jim thank you councillor
brenton where as
um this is a notice of motion i'd like a
couple of things clarified before we
proceed um from the from the senior
solicitor if you would
as it's a note of emotion is it true
that there is meant to be no debate and
we should go straight to the vote
and if that is the case i think we
should actually follow our constitution
for once rather than
ignoring it and doing as we want and say
with regards to this motion if it is
seconded
our members who are chairs and vice
chairs allowed to
discuss or vote on this as surely they
would have a financial
interest here so if the solicitor could
answer that before i
introduce the motion please
right station you're on the spot now
thank you chair um in terms of the the
motion itself
um so as councillor jones has stated
um the member has the who's proposing
the motion has the opportunity to
present that motion
and then it should go to the chair to
see if there's a seconder um without a
debate
um in terms of whether the members
um who have a interest should be voting
i
i think they're gonna have to in this
instance because it's actually their
expenses
um and i full council can't make that
decision to give away another members
expenses
so it's a bit of a a strange situation
on this account
on this occasion but i don't see that
there's any other option
can i just talk to that police chair yes
um we're not saying that the council has
the ability to give away another members
expenses we're saying that
the council here is expressing an
opinion and then it's up to the
individual conscience of the member to
decide what they do with their extra
allowance money does that make any
difference
i think those members are entitled to to
vote on
on that situation um i accept that full
council can't actually make the decision
but it is up to those individual members
um whether they they want to give away
those expenses or not
um and actually this isn't necessarily a
decision that full council
can can make um i don't think i've ever
experienced
um a situation quite quite like this um
and under normal circumstances yes
members would have to
um abstain um but this is a very
different circumstance and i don't see
how we can exclude those members
stop stop i want to raise the point of
order here can i raise point of order
right point of order thank you all
counsellors vote
on their own um money that comes in we
do it every year
nobody excludes themselves it's up to an
individual counselor then if they give
up their money or not
and i i don't follow councillor jonah's
point at all
all right thank you for that point of
order chair
point right disagree just
noticeable motion is discriminatory in
its drafting is it does not treat each
councillor with equality
the councils proposing this motion are
both representing a more urban ward
with a compact geographic area with a
single town council
councillors representing more rural
woods typically furthest away from
biddeford
have larger areas to administer to the
needs of their constituents
and they're frequently unrecompenced for
that this motion makes no
consideration of these circumstances
it's also completely unconsidered
is that many chairs have additional
duties many of whom are lead members
positioned which are devoid of
remuneration but essential for a
political representation of time
as an example additional to my duties as
chair of audience governance i sit on
devon audited partnership
as lead member for health and well-being
i thought on the community
hold on there hold on hold on we do not
want to go through a whole
cv of everybody's duties
responsibilities their
charitable status et cetera et cetera
what was required here i i'm going to
say that uh
what up what i would do if if this is
seconded
if it's the seconded i would urge
members to abstain from this and
treat this with the content it deserves
basically is totally political
i do not need any lectures from
conservative members of this council
over allowances because they've always
voted in favor of increasing them
and i've always voted against them every
time it's come around so
that's here and that's the way i'm going
to rule it so i'm going to go to the
needs of secondary and then i'm going to
go to the vote
i'm not going to let this get into a
divisive argument
so have you got a second mr chairman mr
chairman
councillor dermot mcgough i will be
second in motion but i do believe the
councillors the councillors
should have the chance to actually read
their motion to the public on youtube
they've submitted the motion i support
the motion i second it for him
you saw his second did just tell me you
haven't given a chance to read the
motion that yeah he just pointed clarity
to the solicitor
they have that right as counselors to
notice the ban
on their motion those emotions that when
you're on your um
agenda you have the option mr chairman
point of order you have the option
to digress more on your mo notice the
motion
it says oh dear i'm not asking cancer
i'll read it out and we're going to vote
on it all right if you haven't got it in
front of you i don't know why but you
should have
point of order point of order should it
not be up to the person or people who
have counsellors who have put in the
motion
to read it and say whatever they want to
say um
and then you take the vote but that
hasn't actually happened yet
well we've got councillor jones i
presume you're speaking on your behalf
as well wasn't he
but i wasn't offered to say anything and
he hasn't called the question yeah
point of order chair the motion could be
read out
but if anybody wants to add to their
notice of motion they are themselves
debating it
oh yes is wrong okay i haven't asked to
add anything i'm just saying that that
needs to be read out and for him to see
what he wants
but also i as a joint joint person who's
put the motion in
are you going to second it are you
counselor hutchings i believe it's
already been seconded by councillor
goff off yeah but he was it was subject
to him
understanding what it was said he did he
seemingly didn't know
so you you're reading that then
councillor hatchins go on
councillor jones i let councillor going
to go with it his first name and he was
ready to read it so
okay thank you very much yeah so the
the notice of motion reads as follows
while recognizing that any such donation
is entire voluntary and at the
discretion of the individual counsellor
in light of the coronavirus pandemic
leading to the cancellations of meetings
in april may and june
this full council would encourage chairs
and vice chairs to donate a portion
of their chairs allowance as they see
fit
to our council of grants fund and if i
may as i didn't actually get to
to speak about the substantive nature of
the motion what i wanted to say was
that we have an allowance as members
we all receive the same allowance as
members for going out into our
communities and working hard
i have no doubt that the chairs in
question have been out
working hard in their communities i also
expect
that the chairs have done work in with
regard
to their to their chair roles for them
for these um committees
what i'm saying is that they're
conscious of the individual
chair that if they feel that as as
a point of order point of order this is
now debating it
this is now debating it oh this will
bring up the role of the lead members
who are the judges
finish your point now i'm going to get
another vote the point i was trying to
make was that there are two distinct
grants
and that i feel that as many as many
members of the
of the public have sort of said to me
that if
meetings have been cancelled and a
councillor receives an allowance to
chair those meetings
and their their role as um as a chair
during this period
has been perhaps lessened that maybe it
would be the
uh suitable thing to give a slight
proportion of that
back to the council as a gesture of um
solidarity with the people of torres who
at the moment will be going through hard
times
thank you oh thank you very much okay
so i'm now going to go to the vote check
check if i if i could
i think the the motion was seconded but
it wasn't actually proposed by
either councillor jones or hutchins it
was seconded but not proposed
i'm happy to propose it right cancer
hutchins is happy to propose it
there we have it on the record so
go to the bottom
thank you chair councillor bowton i'm
staying
councillor brenton abstain
councillor bright abstain
councillor brown epstein
councillor bushby councillor christie
i'm voting against because if you're all
abstaining and only two people before
would it get accepted
i'm against all right councillor clark
against councillor cottle hanken
[Laughter]
[Music]
abstain
councillor dart
against pennsylvania
against councillor hackett
it's disgraceful against cancer harding
abstain cancer hawkins
against councillor hicks
against and looking forward to half
price beer in halsey
[Laughter]
i'm looking forward to the hospital beds
coming back
councillor hodson sorry i'm still
laughing
against councillor harley
against councillor hutchins
if you make it before around 10 p.m
councillor hicks it'll be okay
um i'm four councillor wrench
against councillor
james against councillor jones
or councillor langford
against councillor laws
against counselling leader
aren't you signaling the mischief making
i'm against
counsellor mcgrath i got that tempers
fair didn't it i'm four
cancer mackenzie uh as a vice chair and
with an interest i will abstain
counselor manly against councillor
newton
james chancellor pennington thanks but
i'm setting up a charity if everybody
wants to donate
[Music]
sorry chancellor rossi abstain
councillor watson against
councillor wiseman against
two three one two three four five six
seven eight nine
don't worry sandra it's enough
one two three four five six seven eight
nine clearly certain counters don't
realize how hard we
work chair it's
3 4 19 against
and 10 abstentions thank you sandra
well yes we've had a bit of a bit of a
political knock about here tonight a
long time since you have one of those so
there you are
it's in the past now so we move on to
the next uh
notice of motion from cancer cottle hunk
and i have to declare an interesting
start because my eldest daughter is um
a staff nurse at the the north evan
district hospital
but i understand uh councillor con
lonkin and in fact their events have
overtaken us all
for the good is that correct would you
like to um
enlighten us on that one yeah um
i also need to declare a personal
interest and let counsellors know i'm 16
weeks pregnant as well
oh congrats congratulations
and also friends and family effects
so yeah on the 8th of september nhs
guidance was issued
to allow the reintroduction of partners
in maternity services
this was supported by the royal college
of midwives the
royal college of obstetricians and
gynecologists
and the college of radiographers it was
also supported by
six the mps who signed a letter and sent
it to nhs
trusts and was also supported by health
secretary matt hancock
um there was also a national petition
signed by more than
400 000 people um my post on social
media on the 25th of september
about this notice of motion received
nearly 20 000 views
and had 82 shares and now as you say
councillor brenton um i'm pleased to say
that northern devon healthcare nhs trust
announced that there would be changes to
their restrictions last thursday
that came place on friday the 2nd of
october
sorry we're on holiday at the moment
so the changes that came into place
um one partner or designated individual
individual is able to attend the dating
scan
and the anomaly scan they're not able to
stay for any subsequent appointments
with a doctor or midwife
all other scans such as growth scans
should be attended alone although
except exceptions can be made if we
anticipate having to break bad news
if the woman is being induced they can
have a partner
designated individual attend with them
between the hours of 10 a.m and 6 p.m
outside of these hours our staff will
continue to contact partners
and ask them to attend the unit if due
to pain or distress support
is required um one partner or designated
individual
may make an appointment with ward staff
to visit basic wards between the hours
of
10 am sorry 10 am and 6 p.m
and they can visit for up to eight hours
which is a massive improvement
and they've also said that partners can
be present at all stages of labor
so in light of these changes and the
huge progress that has been made
i would now like to amend my notice of
motion
and propose that we still write a letter
at thanking the trust
and supporting the changes they've made
this has
brought a great deal of relief and
comfort to expectant families
and will result in more positive and
fewer traumatic experiences for families
across north devon and torridge
thank you right thank you so that's an
amendment to your own notice of motion
you know you proposed it i second your
notice of motion
um and also what i would uh second your
amendment
that you put forward now so that's
proposed so we take the amendment first
okay that you've amended there sandra
did you manage to write that down
or could you read it back again to us
please uh cheryl
um i propose that we write a letter
thanking
the trust so thanking northern devon
healthcare nhs trust
and to say that this council supports
the changes that they've made
right
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to uh take a vote on
i'm not going to have any discussion
we're going to take a vote on the
amendment first and then we'll take a
substantive vote afterwards okay
so um please uh sandra
thank you chair uh councillor bowton
uh four chancellor brenton
four chancellor bright four
councillor brown four
pencil bushby or answer christy
or answer clark or
ansel cottle hankin or
answer craigie or chancellor dart
for counsellor gab
for pencil hackett
for counsellor harding
or chancellor hawkins oh
henson hicks
you're muted though four
cancel hudson henson hurley
or cancer hutchins or
councillor wrench or councillor james
or ansely jones or
penciller langford for
pencil and laws congratulations cheryl
four councillor leather
or councillor mcgough
four councillor mckenzie
four hanson manly paul
hensler newton paul
chancellor pennington or
unanimous chair thank you and now we
have to take a substantive po
on the notice of motion so do it all
again afraid
chair chair sorry can i just come in um
we don't need to vote on that the first
motion
it was amended um to reflect the changes
that have been made so
councillor cotton can ask for that
notice of motion to
be amended and you seconded that
amendment so um
the amendment to write the letter
thanking the hospital
will stand will it okay oh i'm relieved
about that and i'm sure everybody else
is as well
thank you very much okay um so in that
case we uh
concluded our agenda sorry
councillor james has his hands raised
right
yeah just to say that i discussed this
with cheryl earlier
um and i support the letter and what we
were discussing is quite who would sign
it whether it come from the leader the
chairman
or from cheryl herself um but we'll
resolve that tomorrow
or in the near future okay
okay i think all three do that really i
think actually
okay so um we've covered the business
tonight um
fellow councillors and uh i hope the
members of the public watching in were
uh uh suitably and entertained um but
we'll
see the repercussions of that one thank
you so
i wish you all a very good night and as
i say keep safe in these
troubled times thank you bye